- [Narrator] "Star Trek" is an
iconic series from the 1960s.
It's also one of the most
culturally progressive shows
of its time.
This is due, in large part, to a strong,
unforgettable female officer
onboard the Starship.
- My name is Nichelle Nichols,
and I played Lieutenant Uhura
on "Star Trek," and I did a damn good job.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] The 1960s were the height
of the American Civil Rights movement.
At the very same time, Nichelle
Nichols was one of the only
black women on TV who played a confident
and strong character.
- I want immortality.
- [Narrator] But had it not
been for a certain super fan
at an NAACP dinner,
Nichelle would've never
made history like she did.
- He came over.
He was really excited, and I looked at him
and it was Martin Luther King.
- [Narrator] She told him
she was leaving Star Trek
only after taping season one.
- And he stopped and he said,
you can't leave.
You don't have a black role.
You have an equal role.
And I realized I had a
responsibility to that character,
to all those people out there.
And that responsibility
becomes part of your life.
- [Narrator] Nichelle
would further make history
performing one of television's first
interracial kissing scenes.
In the episode, Captain Kirk
played by William Shatner
is forced by aliens to kiss Uhura.
When NBC executives learned of the kiss
they became concerned it
would anger TV stations
in the deep south.
- The director said we'll do
it both ways with the kiss
and without the kiss.
- [Narrator] So William Shatner
came up with a master plan.
During filming, he botched
the tapes without the kiss
on purpose leaving the kissing
scene as the only good option
to use on TV.
- To a young black woman in
a situation that has never
been done on television, I
realized how important it was.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Years later when the original
"Star Trek" series ended,
Nichelle was hired by NASA
to make their space
program a bit more diverse.
- I recruited people
like me to go into space.
Whether they were black,
white, yellow, brown, red.
People like Sally Ride, Guion Bluford.
I also recruited Mae Jemison,
the first black woman
to go into space.
- [Narrator] Nichelle Nichols'
time on "Star Trek" was
instrumental in advancing the
image of African Americans,
and at a time when such
equality was unheard of;
and for that, her legacy shall ...
- Live long and prosper.
Live long and prosper, baby.